tu vois que là on est en plein de
tendresse comme tout le monde s'en
aperçut on va donc faire une interview
au temps bref
[Musique]
la bri est-ce qu'on vous appelle
toujours l'ours
bourses ont
maigri vous vous souvenez de votre
premier ours en peluche pas du tout il
ya deux semaines quand même voir courte
vous souvenez pas comment il s'appelait
tout ça n'aurait ni ton nom
ça a été dur quand on vous a dit que le
père noël n'existait pas mais moi je me
souviens pas de tout ça un vrai j'ai
pris un coup sur la
mort de la maman de bambi vous vous en
êtes remis maintenant ça va ça va venir
exprès d'avoir des questions si on
atteint vite andré fabre est d'abord
la prochaine vous avez déjà pleuré pour
une fille
ou pour une fille 1 ou comme une fille
non oui comment ils ont une fin
oui pour ma femme ah ouais mais quand
une fille vous quitter avant tout ça
vous vous pleuriez pas
d'accord pour un garçon non je déconne
c'est aussi le cas du
retard ces lignes
le prochain ses paluches une belle voix
comment elle dans l'interview d'andré
cela vous dit souvent je t'aime un
michel
weyland bah oui mais je ne dis pas pour
rien non plus les poches du pont comme
ça quand on dit bonjour votre maman vous
lui dites aussi mention c'est difficile
de sa mère de dire ça non ouais bof moi
au bout ça va rarement vous souvenez
quand vous chantiez
oui et oui
c'est le moment
baromètre
cherchez temps passe en l'état
remettre dans le bain
oh non
c'est vachement bien c'est un texte
sacré en plus on brise un cétacé pas de
la rigolade un salaire net durable comme
ça mais c'est l'évangile c'était un sub
sole en ceinture marron est un super cd
on l'a jamais sorti bah oui mais non là
tu vois nouveau jeu seul passé la maison
un mot aussi puisqu'on est dans les
tableaux en bresse vous fait un bisou
tous les deux là
fabrice tiozzo
surveillant de monde
champion du monde
alors on va faire une interview
tendresse
alors jean marc qui s'appelait comment
votre premier ours en peluche vous en
souvenez votre petit nounours mais
j'avais pas de nos jours vous avez pas
nous le sens peluche ça a été dur quand
on vous a dit que le père noël
n'existait pas
je me demande si j'ai vraiment cru non
c'est à dire et acariès
d'accord et rocky balboa quand on vous a
dit qu'il n'existait pas ça vous a fait
de la peine
ben pour moi il existe quelque part
ça vous a touché la mort de la maman de
bambi
par le
tuer par le chasseur vous a fait de la
peine mazet la mort ça fait toujours de
la peine quand quelqu'un part j'avais
déjà dit je t'aime à votre maman bien
sûr vous lui faisiez quoi comme cadeau à
votre maman quand vous étiez petit les
bourres pifs tient
encore quand j'étais plus petit bain
j'étais à l'école on faisait des dessins
je ramenais dessin
quelle fille nous a fait pleurer pour la
dernière fois jean marc
moi un film qui m'a touché c'est le
pianiste ah ouais c'est dur exigeant
très très beau pull
mais surtout ce passage là
quel endroit le plus romantique vous
ayez fait l'amour jean-marc il faut que
tu prends comme ça parce que je suis ton
n'est plus remonté que vous ayez fait
d'amour six pages et j'ai peu de
souvenirs spots est ce que jean marc
gales a pas encore fait l'amour
jeune senah sport qui se rasent rbb
c'est un groupe
d'amis je suis plus il n'y a pas de
honte un va te trouver une fille mais je
veux une fille
est-ce que vous avez déjà pleuré pour
une fille jean max heyes comme une fille
en dix mois avait non
non mais pour un garçon
bien des fois que j'ai eu peur c'est
pourquoi quand on chante c'est des coups
raconte raconte thierry
la dernière fois peut-être un peu pour
ce combat quand même peut-être un peu
parce que je me suis rendu compte c'est
vrai que je voulais tellement de fermer
après qu'on arrive jusqu'aux qu'on
arrive à adhérer à minute en zee ouais
mais peut-être aussi je peux tout perdre
et je pense que voile sur y est rentré
en france gr 1 et là j'ai peur si vous
aviez une baguette magique quel serait
votre premier voeu
premier jeu c'est tout ce que je vois
tout la misère des fois que je vois la
télé avec les gens les jeunes enfin les
enfants un
qui est put quoi plus de télé
vous aimeriez voir comme un enfant vaut
deux vous voulez un bisou
j'ai très tendre
t'es pas la brute épaisse qu'on voit
dans les films tu veux un visio
justement interview tendresse
[Musique]
il s'appelait comment votre ours en
peluche
harold ça a été dur quand on vous a dit
que le père noël n'existait pas
pleurer deux semaines d'affilée et puis
ensuite essayé de me suicider si je me
suis ensuite
et j'ai disparu plusieurs années je me
suis dit oh type est en fait c'était mon
premier voyage au tibet vous disiez
souvent je t'aime à votre maman non non
vous lui faisiez quoi comme cadeau quand
vous étiez petit coup de bol
quand j'étais petit on visait que plutôt
que tu allais dans une boutique acheter
un cadeau avec l'argent de poche il
valait mieux faire deux choses quelque
chose de nos mains parce qu'ils
s'amenaient du coeur comme ça et donc
souvent j'essaie de fabriquer des choses
pour ma famille pour mes parents pour
leur montrer mon affection
et ma gratitude
c'est quand la dernière fois que vous
avez dit je t'aime à une femme
il ya deux secondes
quel est l'endroit le plus romantique
que vous ayez fait d'amour
probablement au japon vous avez été
mariée au japon dans la salle absolument
oui
c'était il ya longtemps un oui déjà
pleuré pour une fille
tous les jours il est doux et super
sympa super sympa j'aime pas sa veste et
pour un garçon pour un garçon vous avez
déjà pleuré
oui après tout moi j'ai pleuré lorsque
des amis hommes à moi ce sont fait tuer
par exemple elle s'appelait comment
votre première petite amie boylan menad
couronne bac
pas celle dont je me souviens en tout
cas la première dont je me souvienne
c'est étonnant qu'elle s'appelait tom
stone à la tonne à donnacona
la brise de mer qui n'a jamais accusé de
ça encore ouais c'est ce soir
vous voulez un bisou
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus